قال ايفان فيدروف عمده مدينه ميلوتوبل
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه زابوريا ان القوات
الروسيه بدات بمغادره ميناء مدينه التي
تسيطر عليها في المقاطعه الجنوبيه اضاف ان
مغادره الميناء تتم بشكل عاجل حيث تعمل
القوات على ازاله المعدات وتحويل مسار
السفن التي كانوا يستخدمونها في تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه المسروقه وفق تعبيره
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه مقتل شخصين
واصابه اخرين في قصف اوكرانيا استهدف
مناطق السكنيه عده في المقاطعه ونشر موقع
زي فيسدا التابع لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
صورا تظهر تصاعد اعمده الدخان من مباني
سكنيه في مدينه شيبيانكو بمقاطعه الروسيه
واعلن حاكم المقاطعه عن انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي والمياه بشكل كامل عن المدينه
في المقابل اعلن القائد العام للقوات
الاوكرانيه تدمير احدى وعشرين طائره مسيره
وخمسه عشر صاروخا من طراز كروز خلاله هجوم
روسيا الليله الماضيه اضافت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان الهجمات الروسيه تركزت في
اتجاهات دنيا
البلاد كما اكدت التصدي لهجمات روسيه على
محوري لمن ومارينكا وباتجاه كوبيانس
كلاسيه في غرب ماسيو تيفا بمنطقه خاركيف
واكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الغارات
الجويه الروسيه تواصلت على باخمت دون حدوث
اي تقدم بري في تلك الاتجاهات
قال حاكم زابوريا الاوكراني ان مدنيين
اثنين قتل واصيب خمسه في قصف روسيا استهدف
بلده
بالمقاطعه الجنوبيه كما قال المسؤول
الاوكراني ان الروس قصفوا بنايه سكنيه
والحق اضرارا بالبنيه التحتيه المدنيه
واكدت قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه
مواصله قواتها قصفى المواقع الروسيه على
طول جبهتي خيرسون وزابولوجيا جنوبيه
البلاد
وصف المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بالمحتدمه واشار الى ان القوات الروسيه
وقوات احمد الشيشانيه تواصلان هجماتهما
باتجاه جبهه مريمكا في دنيا
نفذت القوات الجويه الروسيه ضربه باسلحه
بعيده المدى ضد انظمه الدفاع الجوي التي
تغطي منشات البنيه التحتيه العسكريه
الحيويه الرئيسيه في اوكرانيا وفي دونتسك
تحتدم المعارك على محور
فيما تواصل القوات الروسيه وقوات احمد
العمليات الهجوميه في اتجاه مارينكا
التكتيكي
معنى من اوديسا مراسل الجزيره تامر
الصمادي ومن دوني تنضم الينا مراسله
الجزيره كارمن جوخادار مرحبا بكما كارمن
كيف تتعامل السلطات الروسيه مع الحديث
الاوكراني عن انسحابها عن انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من برديانس
هذا الخبر حتى لم يتم تدوره على مواقع
المواقع الرسميه الروسيه او المواقع حتى
العسكريه لا حديث عن برديانسك الا في اطار
ما جرى اليوم من استهداف اوكراني لتلك
المنطقه الواقعه على بحر ازوف والحديث عن
استهدافها بصواريخ
البريطانيه ووقوع عدد من الضحايا اليوم
تكتسب اهميتها انطلاقا من موقعها على بحر
ازوف وكانت روسيا قد ضمتتها اليها بعد
اياما من انطلاق الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا في 28 من فبراير من ذلك العام هي
وميلي توبيل كانت السيطره عليهما فيما
كانت القوات الروسيه تقاتل على جبهات كييف
شمالا اهميه بريديانس هي انطلاقا من
مينائها البحري الذي يشكل بناء اساسيا على
بحر ازوف وايضا هناك اهميه بالنسبه
لبريديان سكوانائها انها تشكل امتدادا
لهذا الخط يبدا بماريوبل يصل الى
ميليتوب باتجاه شبه جزيره القرم نذكر جيدا
ان احد الاهداف الاساسيه بالنسبه للقوات
الروسيه في هذه الحرب كانت مد جسر بري من
روسيا باتجاه شبه جزيره القرم هذه المنطقه
التي اصبحت في الفتره الاخيره مسرحا
لاستهدافات متكرره من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه حتى مريوب ايضا اطلق باتجاهها
مرات عده واستهدفت مرات عده في الشهر
الماضي كل ذلك تضعه السلطات الروسيه
والقوات الروسيه في محاولات القوات
الاوكرانيه استهداف تلك المناطق بهدف
استعاده شبه جزيره القرم ولكن السي هذه
المنطقه هي احدى اللاءات وبالنسبه لروسيا
على طاوله المفاوضات وفي الميدان ايضا
تامر صمادي ماذا عن التطورات عند الجبهه
الجنوبيه
وهي كثيره
ويعني تطورات ميدانيه بمختلف الاتجاهات
ماذا تحدثنا عنها
يتطور الابرز هو في برديانس لاسيما
الاعلان الذي جاء على لسان عمده
الاوكرانيه الذي قال بان القوات الروسيه
تنسحب على نحو عاجل من داخل الميناء وتعمد
على ازاله المعدات الخاصه بها واشار ايضا
الى تحويل حركه السفن التي قال بان هذه
سفن روسيه وبانها كانت تعمل على نقل
حبوب الخاصه
بالجانب الاوكراني من المدينه والمسيطر
عليه روسيا وكان يقول على صفحته في
تيليجرام بان السفن الروسيه لن يكون لها
مكانا مستقرا بعد اليوم داخل ميناء
برديانك وذلك نتيجه ما قال انه انفجار
تعرض له الميناء حتى هذه اللحظه كما قلت
المعلومات شحيحه لا تفاصيل لا سيما عن
قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه المعنيه
بمثل هذه التصريحات لكن نحن نتحدث عن
مسؤول اوكراني على راس عملي حتى هذه
اللحظه وهو يقدم هذه المعلومات
الشحيحه على صفحته في تيليجرام لكن استطيع
القول بان قياده عمليات الجنوب طيله
الايام الماضيه تتحدث عن جبهه حقيقيه في
برديان سكوابي بالاضافه الى عديد المناطق
في ريف جبروج الجنوبي الذي تسيطر عليه
القوات الروسيه الحديث عن ميليتوبيل
الحديث عن توك ماك الحديث عن انور جودار
كل هذه المدن التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه وفقا للروايه الاوكرانيه تخضع
للقصف المكثف من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
منذ ايام وهذا القصف باتا يتعاظم يتزايد
مع الحديث الاوكراني المتواصل عن
الاستعدادات المتعلقه بالهجوم المضاد
للقوات الاوكرانيه والحديث حصرا في هذه
الاثناء يدور عن المناطق التي تتواجد فيها
القوات الروسيه فيروجيا وفي منطقه خيرسون
وايضا القصف يطال بشكل مكثف القصف
الاوكراني الحال المناطق التي تتواجد فيها
القوات الروسيه في منطقه خيرسول الحديث عن
الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر هنالك قصف لا
يهدى لا يتوقف وفقا للتصريحات المتلاحقه
المتتاليه التي تصدر عن الادارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في خرسون فيزا بروجيا بالاضافه
الى قياده عمليات الجنوب التي تتحدث في
نفس هذه المعطيات قبل قليل كان هنالك
تصريح ايضا
للمتحدث باسم الجبهه المتعلقه والخاصه
خيرسون وتحدث عن خسائر كبيره للقوات
الروسيه على تلك المحاور وتحدث عن قتلى
وجرحى يزيد عددهم عن سريتين وفقا لتعبيره
في
تتبع هذه السريه
للقوات الروسيه على تلك المحاور وتحدث عن
تدمير عتاد كبير ونقاط تحكم ومراكز سيطره
للقوات الروسيه على تلك المنطقه وايضا
القوات الاوكرانيه في تلك الجبهات تتحدث
عن ق يام القوات الروسيه ببناء مزيد من
الحواجز المائيه عند ضفه نهر دنيبر
بالاضافه الى تلغيم السواحل والشواطئ لذلك
النهر وذلك تحسبا من تقدم اوكراني باتجاه
تلك المناطق شكرا لك اذا من اوديسا
مراسلنا تامر الصمادي وشكرا لكارمن جو
خضار مراسلتنا من دونيتسك